[Musique]
quand vient la fin de l'été
sur la plage
il faut
talât se quitter
peut-être pour toujours
[Musique]
oublié cette plage
baiser
[Musique]
quand vient la fin de l'été
sur la plage
la voix
ba se termine
mais il a
c
doucement sur la place
[Musique]
le soleil
et plus mal
et nous
complices danser
what i
toutain il est maire
notre homme
ange
quand vient la fin de l'été
je la plage et
il faut tu as
sans aller
sont virés
important l'attend
de plus beau
et
[Musique]
le soleil
et plus pâle
et doux
ampli danser
croit-il
qu'après tout intérêt
notre amour a changé quand vient la
foire de l'été
sur la plage
il faut
se quitter
t'es où
oubliée
[Musique]
et
l'obg
baisser
[Musique]